well when you came along with the Mars
trilogy there were a couple things that
were unique at the time one was Mars was
not hip then it's insanely hip now and
you were writing a pretty leftist
economic model on to basically how the
geoengineering the terraforming of Mars
wouldn't lay out is that accurate yeah
yeah that's right and in your mind where
you're doing that is that's how you
could realistically imagine Mars
actually being terraformed or this was
it last a chance of a platform to play
out some of your leftist fantasies well
maybe more the latter when I was writing
the Mars books it was the Viking data
the Viking data came in in 76 and they
gave us a Mars that was a million times
more detailed than what we had before
that mariner and Viking it took a while
to assimilate for science fiction
writers and say well what have we got
here and then it was Sagan and his crowd
that said if you were interested in
terraforming and wanted to plan it to do
it Mars is as good as it gets
it'll never find a place that is more
close to being terraformable and they
began to model it so I was the lucky
recipient of that when I began to write
novels and I saw that Mars would be a
great place to backpack and it resembled
the High Sierra which it didn't but in
green Mars and blue Mars it does it was
yeah it goes like from the Ruby region
Nevada to the Sierra to the Coastal
Range over the trilogy it was something
I wanted to do and then the leftist
ideas is just my my hippy California
Gary Snyder New Age Buddhist you know
you know the drill here I am Gary is a
red diaper baby he grew up with it did
you know no I grew up in Orange County -
a blue diaper baby
whatever it was not a political
household it was a technical and pseudo
a political household pseudo a political
household was it well I I think that the
American technical class would say
happens too often that well I'm just
into technical stuff I transcend
politics or politics is the girl
be stuff and science is the clean stuff
and they try to make an artificial
distinction between the two
so are you basically turning against
feather and somebody get to you with a
more interesting and persuasive frame it
was a combination of Schneider Fredric
Jameson
Ursula Gwyn and the science fiction
community itself I was very lucky in my
teachers all three of those were
teachers of mine at different times in
my life Jameson was my thesis advisor
and he told me to write about philip k
dick the greatest living American writer
at which my jaw dropped I had only read
galactic pot healer and I was looking at
this professor thinking you've got to be
kidding me but I went ahead and I read
Phil dick on on Fred Jameson's behalf
and then Garry was teaching poetry at
Davis when I was there and so I took
classes from him and Ursula came down to
UCSD and taught a science fiction
writing at UCSD so I'm thinking just do
that they tell you have fun
[Music]
you